vous voyez il y a ici des boîtes elles
sont pas là par hasard dans chacune des
boîtes il y a un numéro qui correspond à
quelqu'un du public
une boîte va être choisie et le numéro
de la personne du public qui se trouve
dans la boîte et qui correspond à une
personne du public cette personne
remportera
ce soir
une voiture
elle est dans la cour
ça c'est du cadeau ça ah oui ça c'est du
cadeau voilà claque c'est la voiture
elle part tout de suite
les chéris pour choisir une boîte bien
entendu il me faut une main innocente
j'ai donc prendre quelqu'un du public
puisque je ne peux pas choisir parmi les
chroniques
on va faire ce qu'on appelle pour
choisir la personne innocente
inquiète géant j'ai déjà fait cette
année j'ai demandé à tout le monde de se
lever à tout le public de se lever merci
je vais donner des indications bien
entendu si ça vous concerne
vous restez debout si ça ne vous
concerne pas pour vous rassis
il me faudrait quelqu'un entre 35 et 45
ans Daniel tu peux t'asseoir
[Rires]
il me faudrait quelqu'un
de moins d'un mètre 70
il faudrait une personne avec des
enfants ce serait pas mal personne qui a
des enfants
personne qui a des enfants d'accord
j'aimerais être parce que j'ai très
confiance dans ces personnes là qui
aimeraient une personne qui soit
Sagittaire
[Applaudissements]
pour vérifier merci d'être là merci
comment vous appelez
bien que c'était pas votre enfant non
mais c'est vrai
c'est vous qui allez peut-être faire
gagner quelqu'un dans le public parce
que c'est pas vous qui avez gagné vous
allez faire gagner quelqu'un dans le
public elle va choisir une boîte
quelle boîte choisissez-vous
bien dans le micro
je choisis n'importe quoi
il y a un numéro dedans
on va voir à qui il correspond
c'est quoi votre numéro
le 23 23 23 c'est ma date de naissance
c'est vrai le jour parce que c'est
l'année
le 23
[Musique]
parce que si on prend celle là c'est un
problème
[Applaudissements]
c'est un truc de fou je vais prendre ça
là c'est dingue c'est un truc de ouf
c'est quoi votre numéro 23
[Applaudissements]
merci d'être avec nous
qui qu'est-ce que vous faites dans la
vie
je garde mes enfants regardez vos
enfants vous avez combien d'enfants 3
enfants
je sais que c'est pas évident pour vous
non je sais qu'est-ce qui se passe
actuellement
je recherche
mais malheureusement j'arrive pas assez
compliqué
vous êtes toute seule c'est ça c'est ça
avec trois enfants avec trois enfants et
dur à la fin du mois forcément vu que
tout augmenter
vous avez choisi numéro 23 pour gagner
la voiture bien sûr va falloir faire
quelque chose
déjà remercier
Ibrahim
et Michael de cœur de Bike parce que la
voiture elle est magnifique
car tout bike d'ailleurs je vais aller
voir les enfants
merci ça va les chéris
merci ça va bien ça va
comment tu t'appelles mon chéri
vous êtes en quelle classe
[Applaudissements]
les Chéries j'ai une question à vous
poser qui vous fera peut-être ou pas
gagner la voiture sinon j'aurais bien
sûr à l'autre consolation la question
elle est simple est-ce que tu peux
rappeler ton prénom à tout le public
ça c'est bon
je peux rappeler ton âge
j'ai une seule et unique question à
poser à Killian
s'il répond bien
gagner la voiture
est-ce que tu passes en CM2 oui
la voiture a gagné
[Applaudissements]
l'association humanité qui nous alerté
sur votre cas je sais que vous êtes
vraiment vraiment en galère de fou et
c'est pour ça que je rajoute pour vous
grâce à notre partenaire rose B un an de
course pour toute la famille en plus de
la voiture
vous n'avez plus de sous je sais que
vous allez dans les associations pour
vous nourrir et merci encore
l'association humanité qui nous a trouvé
qui vous qui nous a aiguillé vers vous
qui était complice de la surprise de ce
soir donc merci à eux et donc les
Chéries je rajoute en plus de ça une
séance de Spa pour que tu kiffes un peu
que tu te détentes ça aussi c'est grâce
à notre fidèle partenaire rosbé qui a
été très touché par ta situation c'est
pour toi aussi donc la voiture les
courses le spa
ajoute et je rajoute des vacances pour
toute la famille pour votre ami avec
votre entreprise merci ma chérie
la voiture c'est bon
merci ma boutique Merci à VOUS bah non
restez-moi ça fait plaisir et j'espère
que ça va ça va pouvoir booster un peu
oui je suis sûr bon déjà vous allez
partir en vacances cet été ça vous fait
un peu de bien allez chérie vous êtes
contents les enfants merci en tout cas
d'avoir été là vous êtes magnifique et
Dixie je suis très très heureux pour toi
et on est là on ne lâche pas et j'espère
que ça va un peu te détendre un peu
parce que je sais que tu es tendu par
tout ce qui se passe la galère
et là ça va être un peu moins la galère
oui c'est sûr merci beaucoup en tout cas